what are some of the unique challenges
that we've got with modern mate
selection
well the primary problem and
i do think that it is
verging into a very very very serious
issue
is the imbalance in the sexual
marketplace where there is a
presumably a small percentage of men who
are
receiving the most attention from women
that women want men in the upper echelon
socioeconomically speaking right they
want a man that earns
top 10 percent in terms of income that
has a square jaw line that has a
six-pack you know is is in the top 10 in
terms of height as well and
these characteristics when put together
equate for a very small percentage of
men and if the majority of women are
vying for these men and ignoring the
rest of them
that creates not only a large number of
lonely women but it creates a lot of
sexually frustrated men and those two
things are not are not necessarily or
not even very good if we're looking at
um a prosperous society
why is that a modern phenomenon surely
these impulses have been with us
throughout time
so the impulse is yes the one impulse
being hypergamy so woman dating upwards
is something which has been ingrained
and constant throughout
human existence but i think the three
things which have changed
at least in the last 50 years are
one female achievement so women are
typically earning more than men in a
certain age bracket and they're going to
college at a higher rate so just to give
you an example of the statistics so in
the 1960s there were 1.6 men to every
female at a four-year u.s college
by 2003 there are 1.35 women for every
man in a four-year us college and women
are going to college and earning degrees
at a higher rate than men and this also
applies to postgraduate degrees where
something like 12 percent of women have
a postgraduate degree relative to 8 of
men
and
when it comes to the economics as well
these the press association compiled a
lot of data looking at
economics so earnings and what they
found was that women between the ages of
20 and 29 made on average 1
111 pounds more than a man in that same
age demographic so that's one point the
one factor being
improved uh female attainment the second
factor is that there's a greater
variability among males and this is with
regard to economic earnings and such
right all the characteristics that you
would look for in a viable partner that
there is a wider distribution of men um
economically so making more money
maintaining more sexual partners
and so this variability is of course
going to play to that that top 10
percent of men and the third thing is i
think this is an important one because
it's it's probably with regard or with
relation to technology so an expansion
or globalization of a section of the
sexual marketplace and the collapse of
local of um of local status hierarchies
where things like instagram things like
tinder
are making it such that there's an
international pool of partners with
which you can select from that you
couldn't have before so 50 years ago you
know you'd probably meet someone
a romantic
a romantic prospect you know in a bar
local bar or at a rec center or whatever
it is certainly my parents met locally
right they were maybe from different
villages or something but you know they
it was it was a local phenomenon but
today everything is international
everything is globalized and that all
these characteristics together along
with hypergamy has resulted in this
massive imbalance
how is it if there's women out educating
and out earning men between the ages of
20 and 29
how is it that there's still a commonly
held assumption in the culture about men
out earning out earning women about
women being held back
do you want the the uh sort of dude bro
answer
both give me all of them both well the
dude bro answer is that people are dumb
and uninformed and they typically go
along with memes and messages that's a
joke by the way i don't think people are
dumb i think it's a matter of of just
the amount of information that's being
presented and how it's being presented
because if if members of the media are
just presenting that narrative over and
over again it's going to stick right
it's we're just playing off heuristics
here
uh i think that's the main thing that's
the reason why this narrative sticks
this notion of the gender pay gap is
sticking around despite the copious
amounts of research done about it the
fact that if you actually disaggregate
the the um
the data if you looked at hours worked
if you looked at industry if you looked
at job type occupation these sorts of
things you would see that there's a
reason why it is that men on average
make more than women not to mention the
fact that women between the ages of of
20 and 29 make more make more money than
men with men within that age demographic
what happens at age you know 29 is after
that is probably motherhood so it's not
even a question of men and women making
more less than the other it's a question
of everyone else making more than
mothers
the interesting thing to me i've been
thinking about this for so long is
the presumption
common culture and people that put
forward
this
the idea about the gender wage gap
is that the inherently masculine frame
is the
attainable admirable preferable one that
everybody should be playing on it's like
the um values that we've typically
associated with men or with masculinity
or with men's uh trajectory through life
is the one
those are the rules of the game that
everybody should be playing by and now
we need to kind of manipulate it so that
everyone gets to play that game does
that make sense
uh yeah sort of i think so think about
the fact think about the fact that um
there are a lot of women out there who
might want to
wipe the floor with men and get their
postgraduate degree and earn you know a
grand and a bit more per year throughout
all of their 20s but can't can't wait to
become mothers and don't actually mind
about the fact that they get to become
mothers and yet the woman that decides
to do that is seen through this
particular lens as lesser because she's
decided to play the game that isn't the
typical masculinity approach well why
haven't you only taken
your three months maternity leave
because you know in i think it's in
australia you kind of have like this big
block of time
and you can repurpose it between the man
and the woman across both jobs i don't
really know how that works because the
two companies are going to be different
but uh anyway
yeah why is it that you're not going
straight back to work that to me i must
imagine for women that really can't wait
to be mothers
must provide a level of ambient anxiety
and maybe even guilt around the fact
that they have decided to either be a
mother or go back to work when they
should feel like they're doing the
opposite
that probably has to do quite a bit with
societal pressure so you know women
needing to work or not even societal
pressure but just an economic economic
pressure yes so the fact that both
adults in the household need to work in
order to provide for for everyone else
is a is a clear factor here but to your
point
that that is also an interesting thing
where it is assumed that a woman should
go off and get a job and do and do all
those sorts of things but what if she
doesn't want to
right all this comes down to personal
choice if you want to work and achieve a
phd and be a captive
of industry as a woman you're free to do
so
do it but if you decide that at the age
of 21 or even at the age of 18 before
you even go to a
college
that you want to be a mother you can do
that also i don't see the problem with
it the issue is that people have to
understand that there are consequences
and and
benefits to doing certain things and we
all have to live with it you can't
simply do something and then complain
about the action or the the results of
the action
rolling the clock forward then
you can only have long term
realistically you can only have at one
time one man to one woman unless you're
in some crazy polygamy
retreat somewhere um with that in mind
you would expect women to adjust their
dating strategies
in order to be able to find themselves a
mate but based on the stats it doesn't
really seem like that's bearing out
no no that's correct and i think this
probably comes down to hypergamy as well
is that women
won't settle
well the average woman probably won't
settle she'll probably go after the type
of man that she wants and if she doesn't
get him she's more than happy to be
single
it's more than happy to to work on her
career and do what she needs to do
which is again perfectly fine you do
what you you want to do you do what you
need to do
but it obviously becomes an issue when
there is a lot of men out there without
a partner
without a you know a person that um you
know is there for them and you know
societies where
young men are
without partners
are ones that typically
become to stabilize and crumble within a
short period of time a short span of
time what's happening people if you
enjoyed that then press here for the
full unedited episode and don't forget
to subscribe
peace